avec jean tawil est économiste et
président du conseil économique et
social du parti kataeb bonsoir jean
tamil et merci d'être avec nous on a
évidemment suivi ici abondamment à
l'actualité au liban avant cette
épidémie corruda virus à la situation
était déjà extrêmement compliqué on
imagine que l'épidémie a clairement
davantage encore aggravé la situation
sûrement l'épidémie n'êtes pas lorsqu'on
est en train de voir aujourd'hui ce qui
est en train de se passer dans d'autres
pays
lorsqu'on est en train de voir que les
politiques budgétaires et monétaires ou
bien que d'autres pays ont les moyens
aujourd'hui d'être de soutenir la
population
malheureusement au liban avant même la
crise du coville 19 la situation au
liban était désastreuse on était dans
une grande crise économique l'état fait
défaut de paiement n'a pas pu payer ses
dettes et a fait défaut il n'y a plus de
réserves en devises étrangères dans le
pays pour pouvoir soutenir la monnaie
qui était à 1500 livres qui était fixé à
1500 livres aujourd'hui sur le marché
noir
la livre libanaise sur le dollar est à
4000 livres
donc voilà ça c'était la situation avant
aujourd'hui du fait du coc vie 19
l'économie s'est ralentie en grande
partie beaucoup de de business en train
de nash plus à fonctionner sont visées
de fermer leurs portes que ce soit le
secteur touristique et on sait très bien
combien les libres en compte sur le
secteur touristique ou autre des gens
sont en train de perdre leur travail
et malheureusement l'état n'a pas les
moyens de soutenir cette population et
de se soutenir les gens les plus démunis
aujourd'hui clairement comment réagit le
gouvernement quelle est sa marge de
manoeuvre parce qu'évidemment et
toujours ce fameux curseur entre la
crise économique
et la crise sanitaire certainement les
marges de manoeuvre sont très limitées
au niveau du gouvernement d'un côté haut
niveau ils ont enfin les mesures qui ont
été prises ce sont principalement des
mesures de repousser des différents
paiements que ce soit les les taxes les
impôts ou même les factures
d'électricité ou de téléphone pendant
quelques mois pendant trois mois afin de
donner une petite période de grâce à la
population au niveau de la politique
monétaire et des taux d'intérêt il était
déjà assez bas mais la banque centrale a
donné la possibilité aux aux banques de
prêter à 0 % sur cinq ans afin de
pouvoir aider justement les compagnies à
avoir un peu de liquidités afin de
continuer à payer les salaires
mais ceci dit encore une fois les marges
de manoeuvre sont très limitées alors
que la crise elle elle est beaucoup plus
grande qu'on ne le croit effectivement
la famille estime que le liban va vers
une récession de 12 % en 2020 on se
demande comment ce petit pays pourra
sortir la tête de l'eau est ce que vous
restez néanmoins optimiste ce qu'il faut
savoir ici c'est que c'est tout un
modèle économique qui s'est effondré au
liban avant il y avait un modèle
économique qui était non productifs
c'est un modèle économique était basé
sur les flux de dépôt qui rentrait dans
l'économie libanaise et qui finançait
finalement le système le système en
place
une fois que ces flux se sont arrêtés
une fois que les besoins de les terres
de l'état était beaucoup plus grand que
prévu
ce modèle s'est effondré la seule source
de devises étrangères qui rentrait dans
notre pays n'était que qu'à travers les
dépôts
aujourd'hui on a une opportunité en or
de reconstruire notre économie on a une
opportunité de reconstruire un modèle
économique solide
un modèle économique productif et qui va
nous permettre de diversifier les
sources de devises étrangères qui
rendent à un autre pays que ce soit à
travers
une forte industrie libanaise et on
prenait désavantage compétitif à ce
niveau là qui va nous permettre de
booster nos exportations
que ce soit en créant un environnement
propice à l'investissement afin
d'attirer des investisseurs au liban
mais bien sûr d'autres services et le
secteur financier
mais tout ça a besoin d'abord de d'une
stabilité politique est avant tout une
stabilité politique
après il va falloir entamer les réformes
qui sont nécessaires et qui sont
demandés depuis depuis beaucoup d'années
on se souvient très bien les promesses
qui ont été faites à paris durant la
conférence de s'être ces réformes là il
faut y aller il faut on n'a plus le
temps on a plus de temps à perdre
le premier ministre a dit hier lors
d'une d'une allocution télévisée
comme quoi le liban et on a perdu depuis
le début de l'année jusqu'à maintenant 7
milliards de dollars merci jean tabi les
d'avoir été logique nous en direction
est et français